finde ich auch nicht locker schade
eigentlich nach expertensicht keine
ahnung anwender schokoladen ist da genau
das was das schmeckt und herzlich
willkommen bei einem video
ich hoffe natürlich euch jedes gut heute
folgendes und zwar gibt es im dritten
part von essens tests aus wir euch das
interview
das war auch so ein schöner name
hanks ich merk - essens tests aus aller
welt
heuer habe ich meine freundin die marie
dabei und zwar heute die mir heute mal
helfen
wir haben nämlich die nächste box
bekommt ja hier ist netbox dank an euch
sie schicken mir immer so eine box zu
und ist jetzt zum ersten mal sehen
das sind boxen die kommen dann praktisch
sozusagen aus einem fernen land dieser
welt und da sind dann halt spezialitäten
süßigkeiten getränke was auch immer aus
diesem land drin
wir hatten schon japan und kanada wenn
du das sehen wollt schaut euch sehr
gerne danach an
und heute haben wir das nächste land ich
bin mal gespannt was es sein werde ich
hoffe wieder was sehr interessant ist
aber es war bis jetzt immer interessant
eigentlich und ich habe mir gerade schon
die seiten aufgemacht ich würde sagen du
darfst mal reinschauen und mir dann
mitteilen was das finnland ist das ist
eine frage die man auf jeden fall
bekommt wenn er über 50 liegt das ist ja
nicht so weit weg
trotzdem aber es könnte interessant
werden ihr land also ich war einmal da
in dublin
das liegt schon cool aus man muss sich
einmal umsteigen von oben landschaften
sind heißt es so ist halt wirklich so
also das sieht aus wie im bilderbuch
ok also wir haben
irland hier steht es noch mal auf dieser
karte komme ich erkläre das mal kurz
hier ist immer so ein herz dabei und da
stehen immer alle sachen drin was genau
ist und du kannst jetzt meinetwegen eins
nach dem anderen raus ziehen wir zeigen
dass wir in die kamera und probieren das
auch meist machen wir fachleute für
weitere parks dieses format ist auf
jeden fall immer den daumen nach oben
pressen ganz wichtig ach das ist von
kellogg's ein riegel also so ein
schokoriegel eines alcolocks hat in
irland sein beliebtes reis christie's
müsli einfach als knusprigen riegel im
programm so dass du unterwegs tägliches
essen ganz das urteil an dann machen
augen nehmen den mund
letztens hat mir kanada waren die wiege
allerdings bonn ist hast du nachher
[Musik]
sowie mike ich will es nicht gut popkomm
in berlin
das schmeckt irgendwie so also ich
glaube daher dass zugesagt noch gar
nichts aber es schmeckt wenn ich glaube
das ist so milchzucker nutzer also ich
kann es jetzt nicht empfehlen sagt zwar
andere besser sagen da mal wieder
angreifer rhein wurde dass der nicht
merkt was haben wir denn liga zeigt man
die kamera das bessere comdirect immer
vollständig cadburry karamell kennt in
irland wirklich jedes kind so kult hier
ist die schokolade mit dem cremigen
karamell mit richtiger karamell freund
das wisst ihr ja deswegen bin ich jetzt
mal entspannt
direkt sowie machen dass wir langsam
aufbauen alteriert wenn hier ist
komplett karamell drin ist dann ist aber
vorbei oder was läuft gut
die schmecken so wie diese celebrations
bonbons wo das drin ist es war richtig
gut an rechtlich richtig also wenn ich
davon zwei gegessen haben reicht für die
nächsten zwei jahre sind
aber wir haben relativ früh am morgen
deswegen passt es nicht so dass man hier
mit weitermachen kayapo online rings
online boney m 5 da hast du vielleicht
anleihen du ich gehe ja was macht eure
männer die lektoren meist fehlen mit
geliebten zwiebelringen geschmack wird
ebenfalls von tieto und ergänzen da die
salzige snacks
ich probier einen merkt an ich nicht wir
können daraus japan kommt weißt du als
wir diese japanischen mais riegel hatten
meist chips so schmeckt das lag
vielleicht brauchen diese noch die
eigentlich auch immer der preis dabei
kommt es neben vorwärts weitermachen
ganz kurz habe ich noch nie gesehen
wusste ich auch nicht dass es das gibt
juli hat sogar schon mal gesehen wir
haben hier einfach maß cookies bekommen
am ende sogar das habe ich mir schon mal
gesehen zeigt ja malteser kennt man sagt
das ist ein richtig geiles bams so nennt
man das halt also wenn man so ist so
nennt man das nicht ganz denn das ist
sind damit immer ein kamelle beim
sammeln
die gibt es ja hier in deutschland
allerdings nicht als buttons variante
das ist was neues machen wir auch ich
guck mal kurz was die dazu geschrieben
haben dreimal dürft ihr raten
wahrscheinlich kennt die da auch jedes
kind vom ganzen volk
inspektion malteser baten uns den schoko
stücke aus milchschokolade die mit
knusprigen miles stückchen holzstückchen
was sonst als kugel den gaumen erfreut
ist in der button vor ebenfalls ein ganz
besonderer genuss
wir sind jetzt nämlich ziemlich dünn war
das ist lecker aber das ist meter
vierzig schokolade problem 85 auch gut
jetzt nach mega man ja aber du hast
recht aufgrund der uhrzeit ist das noch
ein bisschen aber trotzdem geil
trackball ganz gut
also hier du darfst wieder rein seit
heute muss man sagen wir haben extrem
viele stars schon wieder malteser
nein das ist auch von milka diese luft
schokolade dazu ja dann machen wir auch
diese nachfolgers sind doch nicht
großartig was denkst du für diese
uhrzeit bisschen liebe luft schokolade
sich minecraft ist auf jeden fall ganz
gut weil es ein bisschen schade dafür
werten dass jetzt nur bei der japan box
und gemeint dabei das war durchsichtige
cola
ich wünsche mir das nächste mal bitte
wieder getränke man es gibt sehr sehr
froh dass die lieber verstecken so marie
dann greift mal wieder rein in die
wunderschöne box eine kamera richtig
cool
das habe ich gerade so von oben gesehen
und ich muss sagen ich vorher noch nie
gesehen dass sich hinter babbel gramm
freiburger kaugummis wie zb die von man
kennt vermutlich karl dambacher bonbons
trend war wirklich jedes kleine kind das
besondere an lebensmittel kommen bringen
dies ist aber du erwartest man geschmack
und dem duft einen ganz normalen
kaugummi bekommst aber eine mischung
zwischen kaum bonbons und gummibärchen
und erwartet aber lecker aber jetzt
einfach
das sind jetzt sollte immer das sieht ja
aus wie radiergummi warte mal hier
wir haben ja noch so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen gold drauf vom letzten video
war wo ich goldene r platz gemacht habt
schauen wir mal ob ihr das essen spielt
man nicht
addiert man aber alle geht leider nicht
das ist kaum mit zum weiterkommen
rom ist war es richtig war es auch gar
nicht so leicht wenn man davon dann mehr
gegessen hat aber du hast recht das
schmeckt so irgendwie voll so genau so
ein mittelding zwischen einem und
gummibärchen und zum schwarm beste soll
schwarm ist halt wirklich total leicht
und gar nicht an und fluffig so und
mauer mit der dicht und fest und schwer
zu kauen und man denkt irgendwie das
weiterkommen
ja und dann ist halt schon vielleicht
muss man es auch weiter kann ein dass
man die ordnung rings die man bis jetzt
[Musik]
die probieren schokolade ein problem
also wenn ich dir jetzt bin ich danach
wahrscheinlich richtig gut drauf bauen
die sind so gut dass ich auch schon
karamell bestehen also müsste ich als
punkte verteilen ist ersten zehn von
zehn besten wo wir doch mal haben wir
nochmal stage es in ihm also wieder
chips kommen wir noch mal ganz schnell
ab und ja noch die master sehen ja aus
wie so ganz normale schützen also nichts
besonderes aber schmecken echt gut waren
die anfallenden intensiven geschmack du
hast im vergleich mit deutschen clubs
[Musik]
im vergleich mit deutschen tipps ja
genau
genau die sind auf jeden fall lecker
also besser also ich habe viele gute
tipps vergessen das kann man schon sagen
auch diese ohnehin länger auch nice und
jetzt haben wir zu guter letzt hier noch
diesem maß cookies nur das ist fast das
gut zusammen
ich bin damit auch eingestand fertig vor
einigen alles und so schwer machen auch
die tipps die frage ist jetzt halt
natürlich kommen du kannst hier ein
kleines stückchen abbrechen
so sehen die ausnahme schmecken die
jetzt nach maß oder hat maas einfach
gedacht also die marke mars und die
gedacht hey in irland da machen auch
cookies also da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt denkmal nicht schmecken ich
würde mal sagen eigentlich überhaupt
nicht ne ne könnt ihr auch nicht locker
schade eigentlich nochmals mit
keine ahnung das schokoladen wo ist da
genau das was das schmecken daher
schokoladig doch da war ich echt nicht
weiter ist stimmt da aber in schlechter
ich mag nicht so gut wie diesen kubica
pol
du hast recht das ist eine richtig gute
zusammenfassung um das video jetzt auch
leicht abzuschließen
leute wir sehen uns dann morgen 19 uhr
schaut gern weil man lieber im vorwald
marie lange ich euch ein und bei mir
auch und ansonsten freut euch gerne auf
die nächste essens box und damit affen
dabei sein kannst du aber nicht weil ich
die jetzt gleich und auspacken wieder
dabei sein
aber du musst du 1000 von
danach kannst du mal wieder dabei sein
also leute haut rein möchte bislang